- [Mark] Isabel?
- No, Ingrid.
- [Mark] Ingrid.
I knew there was an I.
Okay.
- Ingrid.
- [Mark] All right, Ingrid.
- Yes?
- [Mark] Ingrid, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I was born in Downtown LA
at the Red Cross Hospital
but I grew up in what we call Pico-Union
by Venice in Vermont.
And then I moved to South
Central when I was nine.
South Central LA,
most of my childhood until I was 18.
I had my first beer.
Well, I used to drink with my dad as a,
as a little,
I was like seven
and my dad was mad at alcoholic,
he was a mad alcoholic, man.
He would give me beer
and I would drink beer and everything.
And then we moved to South Central
and I stopped drinking
beer and everything.
I know beer is not like that strong
but when you got practices,
like voodoo and everything,
and you know, people do
witchcraft and everything.
So things like that.
And then,
I drank my first beer
'cause I didn't want to grow up, man.
I don't want to grow up.
I wanna stay young
and I didn't want to go to 6th grade.
I was like, "Nah, nah, nah.
"I don't wanna be with those kids,
"they put makeup on,
"they only talk about sex
"and I don't even got boobs."
I don't even...
I just wanted to be a kid, you know?
And then, I had my first beer,
started ditching school
that's when I started messing up
'cause I didn't wanna go to school.
I didn't wanna go to school.
I felt like I was getting
dumber for some reason.
And only one teacher
inspired me a lot, Mr. Brown.
He would always teach me new words
and I have real strong
difficulties communicating
with people.
Unless I'm relaxed with a beer.
I'm really,
I tried mushrooms, acid, crack, meth
and,
but I could only,
it's not my thing
but beer...
I started slowly.
I started ditching school,
I started messing up.
I started like, well, not being too smart,
not making wise choices
in the ghetto, you know?
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- My childhood was in...
I'm the second oldest out of seven kids.
We're poor and everything,
we're living on welfare.
My dad really didn't help us so much.
He would take it away from us.
He would take the money and make us suffer
and live off of beans and rice.
And then sometimes,
around the seventh grade,
sometimes we didn't even have electricity.
But my dad's a pretty smart
man even though he's evil.
He would hook up the electricity somehow.
I don't know, he would do the wiring
and that's dangerous, you know?
And sometimes we only had cold water
and we just, you know, enough
to get by and everything.
Then my folks got divorced
when I was 13 and everything.
And then, I started drinking
at family gatherings a little
bit more, a little bit more,
a little bit more.
A little bit more to relax
as I got a lot of anxiety.
I got a mental illness.
I got schizophrenia, I got anxiety,
I got insomnia,
I got depression.
I was suicidal a lot
for like about, a lot of my years
because I said, man, I'm poor, man.
I wanna succeed and I'm
not the smartest one
so how would I gather the skill,
how would I build up the skill to work
and succeed in life
and take my family out the ghetto?
And I just saw,
I always looked up to my brother,
he's my older brother.
We have seven kids, you know?
And he would inspire me
because he was always good at school,
always good at sports
and things like that.
But I don't know, I'm just mental.
I just,
I think I got dyslexia.
I've got too many mental illnesses.
- [Mark] How far did you go in school?
- I went all the way to 11th grade
but I really,
it was a continuation school.
- [Mark] How serious did
your suicide attempts get?
- I jumped off a third story building.
I tried to get a gun,
I tried to overdose.
I just bled out, my ear blew.
I think my ear drums blew
and I bled
but I still survived.
And then I got over it.
I would drink, drink, drink,
drink, drink, drink, drink.
That was my day.
My mom, I dunno if she enabled me or not
but I would drink and I would say,
"Mom, this is why I am.
I like to drink."
And I would just drink
the whole day, you know?
Just out of depression
and so I could,
just anxiety was so strong
that I needed something to relax.
I didn't need an upper like
meth where I was gonna be like,
you know, tripping.
I needed something to relax,
to relax, to relax, to relax.
And I didn't get my
medication until I was like,
(Ingrid burps)
I don't remember
'cause I also got a lot
of mental illnesses.
I know you're not gonna believe me
but I got like...
I forget things a lot.
I forget a lot of things,
I just forget.
(Ingrid burps)
And,
so anyways, I would drink,
drink, drink, drink, drink
until where I got kicked
out, I got kicked out,
I got kicked out
and I met this homeless person
in South Central
in a homeless shelter.
I was walking in and tryna get a pickle
and then he came out of nowhere
and then I,
I didn't wanna be alone, you know?
At night, not in the street.
So we just kinda like
clicked and everything.
And we became together,
he took me to his family's house.
I would drink, drink, drink
and he would smoke, smoke, smoke
and things like that
but that was us, you know?
And I fell in love with him or whatever
and he got me pregnant.
And my baby was my motivation
to become a better person.
But I always thought,
"How am I gonna teach her things
if I don't know anything?"
They told me, "You want an abortion?"
I left, I left. I said,
"No, I don't believe in those things."
And I had my baby and I was sober
but then I just got so desperate
to start drinking again.
And then DCFS came in,
I think one of the neighbors called them
and they took her away from me.
And she was adopted for about like almost,
only for about a month
because I fought the case.
I did the classes, I did the therapy.
I went to rehab.
I was doing my best
but the addiction was a
little too strong, you know?
And I know it's just beer
but I never get wild with beer.
I never like to get violent.
I never, I don't believe
that beer makes you forget.
Or maybe it does, I don't know.
'cause I forget, you know?
But,
it wasn't meant to be
and my brother, thank God,
he see somebody in life
and then he took,
he got the rights to my daughter.
- [Mark] So your brother
raised her daughter?
- I was still around,
illegally,
'cause I wasn't allowed
visitations or anything
but I would sneak into the house say,
well, you know,
I would visit her.
And,
I even prostituted to
buy her things, you know?
And things,
I tried it but I don't like it.
I think I prostituted like
two times, three times.
She got taken away from me and then,
I couldn't be in the house
because it's a lot of family
issues with my sisters.
They don't like me,
I don't like them.
Except my brother.
And then it just got to,
like it's boiling point
that I couldn't be in the house.
It was like, no, you can be here.
But anyways, throughout that time,
throughout the whole time,
I had been homeless about 10 years.
10 years, yeah.
The first time I was
homeless I was 15 years old
and we lost our house
and we went to a family members house
and then she kicked me out
because she didn't like me or whatever.
And I went to sleep in Hollywood.
I tried to,
I even tried to go sleep by the museum,
Exposition Park and everything
but I said,
"Nah, I gotta beg or I'm too young,
I'ma get raped or something."
Something's gonna happen to me.
I should probably go back
home and beg, oh man.
And then they let me back or whatever.
So what was your question, Mark?
(Mark and Ingrid laugh)
- [Mark] So, you have
just the one daughter?
- [Ingrid] I just have one daughter.
I don't wanna have no more kids.
I don't want,
I don't want them in the ghetto.
- [Mark] How'd you end up on Skid Row?
- Skid Row?
Skid Row, Skid Row.
I don't remember but,
I just would go on the bus,
just to think or, you know, drink
and then somehow I ended up in Skid Row.
I think I will say 23 and I slept there.
Sometimes I even,
well, I think I was going
kind of crazy, you know?
Not 'cause of the drugs
because I only smoke a few times.
I smoke crack.
But I wouldn't drink, drink, drink.
And, I don't know, I just,
depression, demonic forces and
things like that, you know?
And,
(Ingrid burps)
I was raised in the church, you know?
So I believe in the prophecy.
(Ingrid burps)
And I said, "Am I left behind Lord?"
"Am I little behind?"
"Forgive me, Lord."
(Ingrid burps)
I even did naked lady and everything.
I took off my clothes just...
I was just...
Something came over me,
like demonic forces, I guess, you know?
And I started going crazy.
And people would look out for me.
They'd say, "No, no, no,
put your clothes back on."
And I was just like really depressed.
Just really like depressed and,
One time I tried to jump off the 101
and an angel saved me, believe it or not.
An angel saved me.
I tried it to...
I said, "This is the
only way that I'ma die."
It has to be something
that is gonna be like-
- [Mark] You tried jumping off the bridge?
- Off of the freeway bridge.
And,
I got saved by an angel.
And I said, if I gotta live, then fuck it
but I don't feel like I
belong on earth anymore.
I don't feel like anyone's gonna...
If my family didn't love me and everything
because of personal issues
that we had between each other
and because we're different,
if they turn their back on
me, I don't have anyone.
I don't have anyone
so who's gonna take care of me?
I'ma get old one day
and I don't have skill.
I even tried,
I worked before.
When I was 16 I worked at Cold Stone.
You know Cold Stone?
The bestest ice cream ever?
I worked at Cold Stone
but I couldn't like,
I got like mental
difficulties, I don't know.
And I couldn't work the
register or anything.
- [Mark] What do you do for money now?
- Huh?
- I panhandle.
I got it as a side
but I don't have...
I was staying in a rehab
but they were always really...
We have, we have to work,
we have to get up at 6:30
and go to sleep at 8:30
so it was like we had a
schedule where we were like,
we had a program going on.
And I said, "This shit
is like prison, man."
I've been in prison six years
for burglary, Santa Monica.
I took a bad deal, you know?
But I took a bad deal,
well, it was only two years
but I had so many problems with the women
in prison and the C.Os and everything
that I always get another charge,
I always get another charge
until they accumulated to six years.
- [Mark] Did the shame hit,
play a part in your life?
Did shame play a part in your life?
- Shame?
- [Mark] Shame, yeah.
- I don't think so because,
I'm mental.
I'm different.
I just,
I'm a woman,
I'm need help, I need,
I need family.
I don't have family no more.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
you're just on your own?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends now?
- I think I need friends now,
I think I need connects, you know?
- [Mark] Do you have any friends now?
- Nah, I don't have any friends.
I don't have any friends.
After prison everything changed.
My family finally came
through their true colors,
we don't wanna help you anymore.
They told me a whole lot of things like,
like we hate you,
we don't wanna be with you no more,
we don't wanna help you anymore.
And I said accepted that.
I said, "It's okay."
I cried and everything.
I cried, I prayed.
And I died a lot in prison.
Man, I died a lot in prison,
I died a lot in prison.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I'm 34.
I'm still young, you know?
- [Mark] Still young, yeah.
- I'm just so dirty, you know? (laughs)
- [Mark] So your father,
who had alcohol problems,
- Yeah, he-
- [Mark] How did his life go?
Did he get clean?
Did he...
- I pray for him to get
clean and everything
but he's kinda like me.
We like to be on our own.
I like to be on my own.
- [Mark] So he's still
drinking as far as you know?
- I don't think he's
drinking anymore after...
I think he decided to quit
and then he just quit.
He just quit and I was
proud of him, you know?
Even when my family kicked me out
before I went to prison,
we were roommates.
He took care of me.
But he would just feed me
alcohol, alcohol, alcohol.
- [Mark] What do you think
it would take for you to,
that would make you to wanna quit?
- I'm not gonna lie.
I always used to say this.
I don't wanna stop drinking.
- [Mark] You don't wanna-
- Because,
believe it or not,
I'm not a wild person,
I'm not a violent person,
I don't bother anyone.
I'm just calm when I drink.
And I feel,
I feel like I become somebody else.
I don't know.
They told me this...
One of my bestest friends
is Betty Enriquez.
And she likes to do witchcraft.
She always took me to the
(speaking in foreign language),
to the (speaking in foreign
language) and everything
and she said, "Girl, you
gotta in believe in this,
you gotta believe in this."
"You gotta believe in this,
And I said, "No, I don't
believe in those things,"
but maybe I should have, you know?
We used to drink, man.
We used to drink and cry
and eat and cry.
And we didn't wanna be this way.
(Ingrid farts)
Excuse me.
And she did me a little dirty
and then she worked on me and everything
but...
I forgot what I was saying.
- [Mark] So you just,
are you happy?
You seem fairly happy.
- I'm not happy because I don't see why.
Sometimes I wanna die.
I'm still getting back to a suicidal thing
'cause I'm in a lot of
pain, physical pain.
I got hit by two cars,
I jumped off a building,
I got surgery on my knee and on my wrist.
My health isn't so good for being just 34.
(Ingrid burps)
And in prison I got a heart
attack fighting somebody.
Yeah, I got really,
I got a real bad heart attack
when I was (burps)
trying to fight somebody
for a fucking book.
Can you believe that?
For my own book.
It was ridiculous but I
still knocked that bitch out,
I don't give a fuck.
- [Mark] What was the
worst part of your life?
- What was the worst?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- The worst part of my life is
when my family told me, "We hate you."
And that we don't want you,
we don't wanna help you
and,
we hate you.
And,
they told me they sacrificed me.
You believe in magic?
People believe in God,
in demons and Doo Doo and Santeria
and (indistinct) you know?
And,
I guess I was the ultimate sacrifice
and they hate me.
And this is,
♪ This is the way I live ♪
And this the way I live
but I just, I just,
I like being alone a lot.
I always isolated, you know?
I always,
'cause I don't have a secret,
I'm an open book.
But,
I don't, I just-
- [Mark] Are there others in
your family that have similar-
- They are doing the same thing?
- [Mark] Problems with alcohol?
- Just my cousin but he
passed away to COVID.
He passed away to COVID
when I was in prison.
Yeah, he passed away to COVID.
He's like my favorite cousin.
He passed away to COVID and everything.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned
in your life?
- The most important is never quit.
- [Mark] Never quit.
- Never quit.
Never quit.
- [Mark] Do you still have hope?
- I still have hope even
though I get sad, you know?
That's why I think I'm possessed.
because of the illuminati.
Because they did tell me I was sacrificed.
In other words,
but I knew it.
And I'm starting to have doubts because,
I say, "God, I pray you
and I bow down to you.
How come you don't help?"
And I start getting sad,
I start saying,
maybe 'cause I'm an alcoholic,
maybe, maybe because I'm not too smart,
maybe because people don't like me,
maybe 'cause I'm weird,
maybe 'cause I'm poor,
maybe 'cause I'm not too pretty
and things like that.
But can I help those thing?
No, I can't help some things.
Whatever, I don't give a fuck.
- [Mark] Well Ingrid,
well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you, Mark.
- [Mark] I wish you the best of luck.
- Well, you too, man.
- [Mark] Be careful out there.
- [Ingrid] All right, always.
- [Mark] We got you some food.
- [Ingrid] Really?
- [Mark] You can't just be drinking.
This is your first nourishment of the day.
- [Ingrid] I wanna take a shower though.